All right,
in other political news,
Donald Trump is bad
at shaking hands. Take a look.
-♪
-(laughter)
(laughter)
So, that c...
How is it going?
Hey, how's it going?
-Hey, how's it going?
-(laughter)
Hey, how's it going?
-(applause and cheering)
-What? What? What? What?
-What? What? What?
-Are you okay? -I'm okay.
I'm powerful. I'm strong.
You see how strong I am?
I'm the strongest man
in the room.
(laughter, applause & cheering)
-Oh, my God.
-That compilation by...
-(laughter)
-That's the art of the deal!
-I'm okay.
That compilation
by VICE News is way better
than I thought it would be
when I heard
that there was a video
of Trump (bleep) dudes.
(laughter)
It's totally different thing
than I thought it was.
So, obviously this arm-wrestling
match... technique is...
It is some kind...
I'm sure it's something he read
about in a self-help book
that also tells you
to drink raw eggs
and visualize your penis growing
every morning.
-(laughter and groaning) -But
I'm gonna tell you something.
That did not work
on maple-blooded hunk
and Canadian Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau, who...
-(applause and cheering)
-who...
He shut that down!
Shut down the incoming tugs
in one swift shoulder seize
this afternoon. Take a look.
Oh, stopped. It stopped.
-Held it.
-(cheers and applause)
You can't...
This... Guys,
these hockey players.
You can't...
throw them off balance.
-They're used to being
on skates. -(laughter)
"The coach said we had
to shake hands after the game,
but he didn't say
we had to like it!"
That's what those two look like.
So comedians, Trump's...
since Trump's
alpha ploy was counteracted
by Trudeau,
what's a Canadian power move?
Milana.
Affordable healthcare
for all of their citizens?
HARDWICK: Oh, okay.
That's very good.
-Points.
-(applause and cheering)
Can't argue with that.
Tom Lennon.
(in Canadian accent): Uh, hey,
USA, you don't think
that we already have
a sleeper cell inside of you?
(laughter)
Guess what. Give us one reason,
and we activate
the Barenaked Ladies.
-(laughter) -HARDWICK:
All right. All right, points.
-(applause and cheering)
-Very good. Oh, no.
I can al...
I can almost hear that now.
The attack signal is...
♪ It's been...
(laughter, applause & cheering)
-♪ Chinese chicken...
-(laughter)
HARDWICK: ♪ Chickity China
the Chinese chicken ♪
♪ You have a drumstick
and your brain stops tickin' ♪
LENNON: I don't want
that song in my head!
I don't want
-We can't afford. We can't
afford it. -We can't afford it.
-We can't afford the (bleep).
-HARDWICK: And this one.
-And that's sad.
-All right, great. -(laughter)
Like Harrison Ford,
you're getting frantic.
-Uh...
-(laughter)
LENNON: Just speak it.
Just speak it.
HARDWICK: Okay, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. Kyle, Kyle.
-They got a whole city up there
called Regina... -(laughter)
...and we're not supposed
to laugh when they say it.
(laughter)
(applause and cheering)
HARDWICK:
Points for Kyle Kinane.